من أجل جعل أمريكا عظيمة
ومجيدة مرة أخرى ، أعلن الليلة عن
ترشيحي لمنصب رئيس الولايات
المتحدة
[موسيقى]
سأضمن عدم حصول جو بايدن
على أربع سنوات أخرى في عام 2020
لم تستطع بلادنا تحمل ذلك وأقول
ذلك ليس في  ضحك ، أقول إنه بدموع ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى] ،
نحن نحب بلدنا ، أليس هذا
سبب وجودنا هنا ، لم أكن بحاجة إلى هذا ، لقد عشت
حياة سهلة لطيفة للغاية ، هذا
شيء لم أتناوله و
لا يحتاج الكثير منكم أيضًا ولكننا نحب بلدنا ،
وعلينا أن نعتني ببلدنا ،
وعلينا إنقاذ بلدنا
[موسيقى
] ، حيث يتعرض السوق للهجوم
لأن الرئيس
السابق للولايات المتحدة المهزوم رفض القبول.
نتائج انتخابات 2020
يرفض قبول إرادة الشعب
[موسيقى
] سنجعل أمريكا مجيدة مرة أخرى
[تصفيق
] وسنجعل أمريكا عظيمة مرة أخرى
شكرًا لك.